اتمنى الان من رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره
وليد العمري وليد اذا حدثنا عن التفاصيل
ما حصل فجر اليوم في نابلس
قوات الاحتلال اقتحمت مدينه نابلس وكذلك
مخيم العين واستهدفت منازل الاسيرين كمال
اسامه الطويل وكمال الجوري المتهماني
بتنفيذ الهجوم المسلحه على مسيره وقوات
الاحتلال في اكتوبر الماضي قرب بلده دير
شرف التي تجاورها ومقامه على اراضيها
مستوطنه شابي شمرون حيث قتل ضابط اسرائيلي
في حينه وكانت قد اعتقلتهما الاسبوع
الماضي
وما فعلته اليوم انها دهمت المنازل بشكل
وحشي وفق ما افاد به الاهالي واصحاب
المنازل هناك وقامت باجراء عسكري يعرف
بعمليه المسح الهندسي لمنازل العائلتين
وذلك تمهيدا لهده لهدمهما في اطار
العقوبات الجماعيه التي تمارسها ضد
الفلسطينيين خاصه ضد عائلات المقاومين
الفلسطينيين خلال ذلك
مواجهات مع محتجين ومواطنين فلسطينيين وقت
الاحتلال استخدمت قنابل الغاز المسيل
للدموع وكذلك الاعايره المطاطيه وقنابل
الصوت الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني افادها
بانه عالج نحو 20
خلال هذه العمليه
في نفس السياق قامت قوات الاحتلال ايضا
بابلاغ عائلتي الاسير الفلسطيني الاسلام
الفروخ من مدينه رام الله والمتهم بتدبيري
وتنفيذ عمليتين
تدبير المتفجرات وتنفيذه عمليتين في
نوفمبر الماضي وذلك بانها تستعد لهدم منزل
العائله واعطتها فرصه التوجه الى المحكمه
العليا اذا رغبت في ذلك لكن لم يصدف حتى
الان ان قامت المحاكم الاسرائيليه بالغاء
قرارات هدم عسكريه هذا الاجراءات
الاسرائيليه الانتقاميه تتواصل في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه طاق واسع وهي مرشحه كما يرى
الفلسطينيون للمزيد خلال الفتره المقبله
وهو ما سيجر مزيدا من التصعيد على طول
الضفه الغربيه وايضا في مدينه
القدس
اضافه الى هذا كله كانت هناك اعتقالات في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه ايضا حيث اعتقلت قوات
الاحتلال وفق الاحصائيات الاوليه التي
وصلتنا 10 من الفلسطينيين في انحاء مختلفه
قامت بمداهمه منازلهم في منتصف الليل وفجر
هذا اليوم واقتدتهم الى معسكرات للتحقيق
معهم كما تفعلوا في كل يوم تقريبا التطور
اللافت وما جرى في نابلس وهو استهداف
منازل عائلتي الاسيرين الجريح الاسير
الجريح اسامه الطويل وكمال الجوري
المتهماني بتنفيذ عمليه قرب مستوطنه شمر